Let's talk about a smarter approach.
Our first goal doesn't need
to be maximize the value for
the largest weight possible.
What if we tried to maximize the value
for the smallest weights possible,
then kept adding them together
until we had our maximum weight.
Let's look at an example.
We start by creating an array, which
we'll use to store the maximum possible
value for
every weight up into our weight limit.
We assume that the weights
are all positive integers, so
the indices in the array
represent those weights.
We initialize everything to zero for
now.
These are objects that we're trying to
fit in a knapsack with a weight limit
of six.
We take out the object
with the weight of two.
We can update the value at index
two to the value of the object,
then we'll update everything after
it as well with the same value.
Even if our knapsack can hold six,
we've only seen one object so
far, so we need to base that
best value off one object.
We look at the next object.
Again we can't change
anything until index five.
The value of this object
is bigger than the max and
it takes up the whole weight.
So we replace the max value for
weights five and six.
For the last object, the first thing
we could possibly change is index four.
This value is less than that one so
we leave it alone.
We look at index five and compare it to
our value plus the value at index one.
Since the old value is larger,
we leave it as is.
At index six we add our object
value to the value at index
two and end up with a bigger value,
so we replace it.
And we've solved the problem.
This may seem unnecessary with
an example this small, but
imagine how much time we'll
save with lots of objects.
Here, we're taking advantage
of the table to store
precomputed maximum values.
So we only need to do the work
once to get those numbers.
We go through every object and check
if it can increase the maximum value of
every possible weight up
to our maximum weight.
Thus, the runtime is n times W,
where W is
the weight limit of our knapsack and
n is the number of elements.
This is a pseudo
polynomial time solution.
A true polynomial runtime wouldn't
have a variable besides n.
I reiterate, polynomial time
algorithms are much faster than
exponential time algorithms for
big numbers.
So the solution here
is generally faster.